well talks are continuing in doha
between the afghan government and the
taliban but as they discussed the peace
process back in afghanistan violence has
intensified
just months out from the deadline for
the u.s to withdraw
most of its troops hundreds of afghan
civilians have been killed and
injured since the start of the year as
the security situation there
deteriorates
well the taliban has been steadily
taking control of districts across
afghanistan al jazeera has confirmed
that more than a hundred districts are
now in the taliban's control
you can see them in red spread across
the country in 20 provinces
okay let's go live to osama bin jawed
who's been following those talks for us
in doha osama throughout all of this a
lot of the emphasis have been placed
on discussions and agreements that have
been made between the u.s
and the taliban there must be questions
i would imagine over what role
the afghan government can play in all of
this
well that was the the biggest uh event
which happened last year was that it
after two decades of fighting
uh intra afghan dialogue afghan sitting
across the table with afghans who had
not spoken to each other one side
belonging to the taliban and other from
the afghan government this
opened that negotiation but it hasn't
come forth with the results that people
were expecting
because there is a lot of complicated
issues involved as you just mentioned
in the last few weeks the momentum seems
to have changed on the ground
in afghanistan where the taliban have
again taken large swathes of land
they're moving on to district centers
and
there are many places which they have
taken without even fighting for it and
to discuss that
we have with us mr nadidi an important
member of
the committee which is negotiating with
the taliban thank you for taking the
time
describe to us why has so much of
afghan territory fallen to the taliban
and is that not a failure on the part of
the government
well usab we we need to qualify
when we say so much of african territory
afghanistan is a
vast geography there are districts that
has very limited number of
population who does not have uh in terms
of
both the importance of its it it
its uh administrative unit but also in
terms of the population
uh is not called and categorized as a
strategy
and there was an intentional decision
that centers of population needed to be
protected because the
attacks on civilian population have
increased significantly
and then when certain capabilities were
diminished that
protection of those uh smaller
not say strategically significant was
not possible we needed to
pull out of those those areas to protect
civilian population and the populist
areas
that of course had a as part of that
process
it had an effect and the effect was that
in some places
places were taken psychologically
by creating that environment of a lot of
pr and other issues attached to the
places where we
pulled out uh intentionally by our own
districts it is 100 plus districts
are all those districts from 400 100
uh are the districts that somehow the
taliban could claim that they are
they're controlling it's not that all of
them
fall apart just in the past few weeks
it's time of transition and in
transition the ambiguities are large
until the information comes out and
until everybody
settled down some of these are an impact
of what we have pulled out
and created a different psychology and
some
not less significant
some notable districts also
gone into that but our forces of working
back taking back those
centers of population the important
question is
this now are we going to continue to
fight forever
or we are going to sit on table as we
are here ready genuinely with with a
complete fate
to start finding a political solution
for that an excuse that existed there
were foreign forces in afghanistan and
that's why we are fighting is gone
it's no more valid now what is valid is
to protect our
people to protect the gains we have had
to protect the freedoms of our people
injuries and the infrastructure what's
happening now
the space is being dealt with
in a way that is in disadvantage of our
people and its future
infrastructure is blowing up population
civilian population are
made human shield and they are losing
and suffering their life
change that is the situation on the
ground and people on the ground in
afghanistan seem to be losing hope
up in this whole process that there is
going to be intra-afghan dialogue there
is going to be some sort of an agreement
between the taliban and the afghan
government
where the taliban seem to have the
momentum behind them as the foreign
forces are pulling out they are taking
more territories
do you fear that the afghan government
is losing
its grip as there's lots of talk about
uh the government collapsing maybe in a
matter of months
well this kind of assessment of being
there
long time ago throughout the past 20
years there's been number of
intelligence report that always have
been
making assessment and predictions of
course they may look to some of the
indicators they do not look to the other
indicators
a lot of people are up there taking arms
and asking the government to allow them
to fight against the taliban it's a
popular
kind of reaction to the type of
militarism
and and a military
push for taking over territory that's an
indicator that one need to
take into consideration the other key
indicators wherever there is a fight and
there is a district that has fallen
you see a massive number of population
leaving that district and moving to the
area where the government is
it's a clear indicator that people don't
want to
live under that kind of circumstances
why they don't go
a district down where the taliban
already had a control they decided to
come to the government area
now making a judgment that the
government would collapse as a false
judgment allow time for the clouds to
settle
for the transition to complete and the
ambiguity around that to be cleared
i'm a firm believer that the only
solution to ending this conflict
and a win situation for all afghans be
it us
the government the islamic republic of
afghanistan and the taliban
is to agreeing on a political settlement
on table
and that's why we are pressing for the
important issue of a political
roadmap to agree on that to talk about
the important elements of it
so that we can quickly agree on a
political roadmap and we stop the war
and reach to a ceasefire where we can
build an afghanistan that all
uh all of our people and our children
wants to see
mr nadry thank you very much for your
time there you have it the view from the
uh a view of hope from the afghan
government that there is still time to
reach a negotiated settlement
a talks have been ongoing there has been
a meeting between the two sides in the
last 24 hours
and the doors of negotiation are still
open
but as this happens in doha the fighting
on the ground in afghanistan continues
and the people of afghanistan continue
to suffer osama thanks very much indeed
osama bin javid